katie is it jackson good afternoon katie
um how can dr d and i help
yes i have a question about their homes
um my husband and i started our babysit
journey in july
2019 and we are finally on our last
set which is my um 52 000
in student loans we have not paid on
them in over five years
and we were wondering if we could offer
a settlement a lump sum or should we
just start doing the monthly payments
uh no are they in collections
um yeah are they in collections are they
just deferred
they are not deferred anymore they are
in [ __ ] so these are
these are private loans um
no they're federal okay cool uh i mean i
would call them and see if they will
more than likely they won't accept it um
but i would definitely give them a call
and just offer them something how much
can you put towards them
right now if you could because you know
settlement is pretty much one lump sum
yes right now we have just under 20
000 and that's not included in our
emergency fund
yeah i would just start making payments
i would call them and just uh
immediately um go ahead and put that
twenty thousand dollars down on it right
now
and just start making payments towards
uh the rest
um you say you've been doing the baby
steps since 2019 right
okay so you weren't making minimum
payments since 2019
yeah okay all right how come you just
stopped paying on them
well actually i never really started i
was in school and then i went back to
school so they've been deferred and
deferred
um and then we just never started paying
off we were within paycheck to paycheck
and not really making the best decisions
when we were younger um but then we woke
up and had our wine
and in july 2019 decided to start paying
off all the debt
we paid off a little over 70 000 so far
hey that's amazing
what's your household income right now
right now it's 120. we started
around 85 and we've updated this last
year's 120.
awesome how many kids do you have five
five cool katie
so here's the thing you got five you got
a lot of mouths to feed you
you put that 20 grand towards them today
then immediately goes down to
what 42 thousand right and making what
you make
you guys can hustle and hustle and
hustle it's going to be a grindy year
and nobody wants another grind a year
after the
the last growing year especially with
five kids but go just get it done
yeah yeah katie are y'all on the budget
katie
oh yeah we are detailed that will be
done by august
okay so it says you'll be done by august
of this year or next year
this year oh awesome very cool we'll be
good then
yeah absolutely that's good i like that
katie yeah
congratulations i love it so yeah just
go ahead and put that twenty thousand
dollars towards it give them a call and
ask them if they if they will settle
um it depends on i don't know i mean
private loans i know that you can get
them to settle um
some agencies depending on your
financial situations will allow you to
settle but more than likely they will
not
um because you know you can't even file
bankruptcy
on student loans and so it's just very
tricky on those
but give them a call and say hey can we
work out something we got 20 000
as a lump sum we can give towards it
right now can we knock this down get
some interest not down maybe
but more than likely they won't if not
just hey just attack that other forty
two thousand dollars become debt free
so that way you and your family can move
forward all right katie